certains se rencontrent pour la première
fois en cette fin du mois d'octobre
depuis le 2 novembre ces praticiens ont
commencé à exercer dans ce centre et
nîmes ont atteint leur point commun ils
travaillent tous autour de la
périnatalité travailler en fait en
pluridisciplinarité
travaille avec des collègues et pas
seulement tout seul dans son cabinet et
c'est surtout en fait la prise en charge
globale du patient et dépassons les
efforts et les technologies qu'ils y ont
mis enfin moi en tout cas c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est assez rare dans
mon domaine
on a quelques quelques praticiens avec
nous moi je travaille avec quelques
infirmières voilà mes mais c'est souvent
assez limité en tant que psychologue
c'est vrai que c'est tellement
enrichissant de pouvoir parler avec
d'autres professionnels qui sont plus
axés sur le physique ou et toutes les
autres professions parce que c'est la
richesse de l'interdisciplinarité 14
professions sont représentées dans ce
pôle périnatale les praticiens tous à mi
temps se partagent cette cabinet dans
ses locaux 2 175 mètres carrés à
l'origine de l'idée un couple parents de
deux enfants on a eu deux enfants avec
ma femme est en fait on a eu cette
problématique justement ne pas avoir de
praticiens disponibles à proximité
nous vivons à montigny-le-bretonneux
du coup c'était l'opportunité justement
d'apporter une solution à toutes les
personnes qui vivent à proximité qui
n'ont pas besoin de courir situé dans
les locaux dessus de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines paul cherche à
compléter son équipe avec un pédiatre et
un gynécologue